Scott came in and the guy was basically
saying that in a past life that we were
together and that we're soul mates
seems like you have to decide if you
want to be together or not be together
will they or won't they are they meant
to be or aren't they the Kourtney
Kardashian and Scott Disick saga
well continues on Sunday's Keeping Up
with the Kardashians the crew sought out
spiritual guidance in Bali Kourt and
Scott did their session together
obviously because that's not weird at
all
every soul will have a soul mate
it's up to you how you want to end up
this life together enough together when
the spiritual healer tells Cordia myself
that were soul mates
it's a lot to hear I don't really know
what to think I'm in another
relationship I just want to take
whatever good away from it as I can
exactly Scott is literally dating 20
year old Sophia Richie
but of course we can always count on
Khloe to be a voice of reason if I was
Sophia I would be so insecure
I don't know how confident you are it's
me weird if you're Sophia I mean Sophia
knew going into this that I was
extremely close with Kourtney she was
like listen I will never get in between
you and your family and your children
just speak to me and make me comfortable
that's very mature of her I don't know
if I could do it that's right I couldn't
yeah very mature of her I'm a better
person than I am I mean I just really
wasn't expecting that this is what was
gonna come out of this reading it's a
lot to take in and the episode leaves us
with little answers
yeah because it seems the court in Scott
saga will continue I definitely don't
want to disrespect my relationship with
Sophia because it means a lot to me and
the weather Kourtney and I are soul
mates or not I feel like I owe a lot to
Kourtney for the times that I missed
when I wasn't the best partner to her so
I feel like I will forever be making up
for that lost time for the rest of her
life I don't know what the definition of
soulmate is but Scott night we're going
to be in each other's lives forever like
we are soulmates
in a sense you know no matter what
whether were ever together again or not
and because they are just so darn mature
Kourt and Scott also sat down to talk
co-parenting in a new video for quartz
Poosh site people will either look at us
like we're crazy like I'd rather people
look at us like we're crazy and we get
to spend time together and raise our
family together than doing it the other
direction and there we have it honestly
it's getting harder and harder to keep
up with the Kardashians but I will
forever be team Scott and Kourtney let
me know what you guys think though and
make sure you are subscribed for all the
latest on the Kardashians and more until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now
[Music]